you
hi everyone it's Jerry Mon Ches calm and
I just got paired up with Carlson
crusher alright let's see this is a 3-2
game so let's see what we get here okay
we're gonna go in for g3 Bishop g2 so
immediately with this last move I could
focus my attention on d5 in fact I'm
going to go for an eventual night
journey nighty 2 C 2 e 3 and d5 this is
a permanent weakness so could base a
plan off of just one weakness here
there'll be some plan with a 3 and B 4
or some idea to expand with a b4 break
this this plan here is aimed at
restricting this advance and it's quite
timely notice if Bishop here it's
prepping d5 but my knight would be here
just in the nick of time to prevent this
advance I think this might be one moment
where before I commit 293 I can consider
B for since my knight on c2 is
supporting this advance right now so
instead of this idea of a 3 B for an
immediate rook to b1 which is useful in
that it gets off of this diagonal at the
end of the day I still need to stop the
d5 advance though yeah cuz c4 is hit so
let's do this defense e4 and prevent
this so it was at least a good try to
try and get in b4 making use of the the
temporary position of the night on c2
this is still useful because this is an
idea and now on that move I think I want
to stop efore I got to do this anyhow to
free my Bishop so dude III on F forum
and to make use of this square
I didn't go on this journey for nothing
to get to e3 this is the destination so
let's see it could be difficult
well my bishop has already opened up
here has direct sight of the black
position a 3 B 4 I'll try to get that in
if it's prevented if it's prevented I
get the B 5 square that I can maybe make
use of so let's try this first
I'm expecting a 5 and then I'll either
consider 95 or Bishop to d2 not quite
sure if a sig now a 6 wouldn't be played
that would just be weakening so let's go
right in for this all right so they're
going after the light squares huh I
could get this b4 move in now by night
while on c2 and e3 is about supporting
before let's go for it
oh hang on for a moment you know what I
might want to do actually I'm a bit
fearful of this Knight coming in here in
connection with f3 I think now's the
time to actually take here and displace
one of the pieces because Queen takes is
impossible drop the bishop so the knight
has to go in reverse first I think
that's a very important point because
I've inconvenienced one piece I've
forced piece backwards alright so I have
to be careful of my light squares now
the number one defender is not around
two could secure those squares if I play
f3 Knight f5 into e3 could be a problem
hmm
so okay they're preparing to take with
the beep on I guess I'd like a queen
trade because I feel my king is a bit
more vulnerable I think I may need to do
this no take first yeah I'm going to
first let's see how they recapture with
this problem I have this square for my
night let's make use of this yeah I
think I may need to do this move f3 my
ID will be a 4 a 5 let's see this
capture would just be super helpful to
me let's get a 4 a 5 in I got some
potential pin here but my night is uh no
pressure on my night interesting
position I'd like to again trade down
some try and play against this guy ooh
not consider that well I don't have much
choice I guess they're gonna go in for
this huh and at the end of it there on
the f3 pawn okay that's something I
overlooked but I should I should still
have some play um I'm gonna draw I'm
gonna drop f3 not much I could do about
it
no no no no no I could do something
about it well let's develop Knight f5 is
coming now huh huh well I'm gonna give
that pawn up let's get some activity
rook on the 7th strong night here
tough to challenge I mean you could
remove the defender of him when the
capture does occur on f3 the rooks are
restricted in some sense I have some
security over f2 ok now now let's take
they have to take with the pawn
otherwise this drops and now I'll play
here knowing that there isn't going to
be a knight challenging this huh tough
call in this position I could maybe look
to maneuver to the d5 square he's
vulnerable he's unprotected might come
under fire tough to get at the both the
d4 and c3 are defended with minor pieces
how to activate let's go here and maybe
that wasn't the best maybe I should have
maintained pressure here maybe Knight
here is gonna happen
yeah okay let's get to the seventh rank
though let's actually do this let's
restrict this rook just so it doesn't
look to get active in fact I may be
threatened to win not the game but upon
with rook b1 and then some ID of a pin
if work here rook b8 Bishop takes pawn
might be difficult to defend this beep
on so now this is a good rook or a good
versus bad bishop situation and now
they're curling up in a ball so this
move allows me to now seize control of
the seventh rank have to be a little bit
careful of this a 2s or a1 square I'm
not afraid of that an additional pawn
push so I want doing this too and before
this maneuver I want to be able to go
from a 1 so here in one shot maybe I
should look to first restrict I got to
move let's get to the seventh maybe back
rang stuff huh they're very passive now
and we're about even on time so let's
continue to move forward maybe no h4 f4
is probably an idea yeah let's try and
be disruptive to the rooks position ooh
all right we're gonna get these guys
rolling g4 f5 um I don't really want to
trade let's give it
now let's stay active my rooks are more
active so hmm maybe I can't avoid that's
hang on
almost lost on time roof was a close
call
okay let's stay right here let's give a
check hmm they're in a pin let's do this
get my king working he's not doing
anything so hmm let's come over here
maintain this tension although I could
have taken a bath in there on this poem
actually come to think of it I could
take and unrep takes they take the
b-pawn that's a blunder I'm threatening
a fork now let's kick him away
rook c3 they're really in a ball king e4
and f5 will be the road to victory I
think didn't really see that but I want
to just improve my king position they're
really in a giant knot let's keep
pushing
definitely welcome this trade can I win
this bishop ending up upon definitely
can now this is they gave up a really
good important square here but they had
to stop my op on advance so these guys
will push through it's like I'm up to
pawns here really is this one guys
restricting - I just have formed a
little wall here I could easily come
over here and pick up these guys now
there's no rush and the squares covered
they'll probably resign around here and
actually let's just come over here and
push through finally okay I guess that's
actually matin - all right they resigned
interesting game yeah before I we look
at as usual with stockfish I'm wondering
a little bit about what position it's a
bit fearful
right here of this Knight d4 move and so
that said I think maybe Bishop h3 is a
bit mm a bit premature I wonder if it's
best to first make use of this square
with right here on this move Knight d4
instead of Bishop h3 hmm and then and
then think about this Bishop h3 move
although it still isn't done just yet
because of the capture but uh yeah I
think I was very tempted right around
this point to play b4 him glad I caught
this idea to first inconvenience and
opponent's fees if you get out make a
capture and have your opponent recapture
in retreat I think that's quite useful
to you so but we'll see what has to say
I'm I'm thinking this might have caused
me some trouble Knight d4 not going in
for this right away I wonder what the
plan would be we'll see what the
computer has to say but yeah certainly
got a bit scary here with this f3 idea I
didn't I didn't see I didn't see that
idea I damage the structure and I wonder
if there's a more active plan that black
and take on here cuz I am threatening to
win this pawn on d6 if they're taking
away this pawn drops yeah it's I think I
think white is the better side because
of the strong knight on e4 and the
bishop that on g7 that really isn't
playing he's just a super uh he's just a
super super piece knight on e4 but uh
we'll have to see what the computer has
to say so I'll give me a moment and I'll
go ahead and bring it up okay let's see
where there's some way to improve here
as mentioned the plan will revolve
around d5 this little Knight journey
that I went for
so let's get to a more interesting point
in the game Bishop e6 so pretty even ish
position 94 even at this moment is being
called for okay didn't like this idea of
a three huh because of how black can
reply with f4 I mean okay it's still
even if but instead of a three it likes
going right in for 9500 you know what I
was um I was referencing with my knight
on c2 this would be for advances being
prepped and later in the game I was
mentioning when the night is on d5
before is being prepped so I could maybe
be saving myself a move huh making use
of this square in other words going to
in going where he wants to go anyway and
maybe this move is back on it may it may
appear that black can do in between
moves like I don't know just making a
passing move I'm thinking before can be
played yeah this idea to remove the
defender here and then capturing this
square isn't working because after the
recapture it would be with check but
yeah I should have seen that and I can
be in two different locations c2 or d5
to facilitate this before advance in you
can maybe do without this a3 be for
expansion this is quite typical to go
forward with this it works well in
connection with this being counted
Bishop have two pieces converge on a
single point single square can be
difficult to defend against two pieces
applying pressure in two different
directions but yeah I should have really
seen I should have looked at it like
that the knight on d5 is aiding in the
b4 advance okay I mean with eights free
instead
I should h3 it likes okay this is what I
questioned a little bit like d4 it likes
to take and then play b4 okay C takes B
oh yeah cuz another thing is that this
advance is not available now because the
pin although I you I would still be a
bit hesitant I know the computer would
go right in for this but for a human
it's a bit scary to give up the light
square bishop yeah but uh-hmm
giving up these light squares you
envision a queen getting down here
establishing upon an f3 or something but
oh yeah anyhow for the moment this B
pond is pinned so this typical reaction
to be for supporting c5 with the beep on
is ah maybe not on here but okay that's
how it follow up and that here
centralizes the night but the square
gives up is b4 so fish of h3 and he
crazy tactics missed hmm it's going
straight in for the capture I would have
recaptured I think with the rook on C
takes B it likes a takes B as a top
choice I think this is fine too and not
too bad an option okay Bishop takes King
takes as you are seeing here pretty even
throughout Knight f5 yeah this is uh
it's a really nice square Knight right
behind upon here it's the d4 square in
mind III as well really strong Knight
positions for both of us it's hard to
say whose is better I mean I have
pressure on c5 so this connects well
with this type of advance there's an
immediate downside to taking it to maybe
trying to get away with taking in this
way as Uglies it to me up here due to
the pressure on c5
it calls out for f3 in this case which
is super weakening like big-time
weakening d4 III are givin up in the
night is observing both fortunately I do
have the bishop around and c1 and that's
where he'll stay he's not going anywhere
his uh his main job if I'm to play f3
his main job is to basically just sit
there for the rest of the game and watch
over e3 there maybe a timely kick of the
night does give up h4 but I'd be happy
to have in a position such as this I'd
be happy to have the Kings side
completely closed down I'd also like to
kind of teleport the bishop to f2 and
then getting this g4 advance in you know
the knight is basically offset and I
could already start to envision this
position where it's a really good night
versus a bad Bishop envision it in a way
where the bishop is kind of offsetting
the knight and then I could go forward
with this slow but effective minority
minority attack eventually creating a
weakness in the black king up on the
Queen side that I could then target and
this ultimately will translate into what
exactly well restricting the black
pieces in some way will have to tend to
those weaknesses and defend but uh okay
interesting double up calling for f3 all
right now a4 as well so I guess f3 or a4
at this point I didn't see the f3 idea
by black it is a move still holding it
as even ish let's give it a little bit
of time here to think it's nothing bad
for white but yeah they're certainly
getting inactive okay yeah I guess it
doesn't like this idea yeah
it's approaching upon advantage now I
guess just the wrong idea with this f3
move it's still liking Knight f5 instead
and I would have been consistent here
with a5 I could take here this check on
c3 I could just get out of the way
block it's just an ugly move to do it
like that but uh yeah I'd continue with
this upon advance huh 96 challenging the
strong night their night takes Queen
takes and now f3 and now it's a once
again a playing against the bishop it's
either you try and get it as white you
try to acquire position as white where
you have a good night versus bad bishop
or a good Bishop in this case versus a
bad bishop bad because he's restricted
by these guys these are pawns that are
fixed on the same colors he him somebody
will correct me okay anyhow f3 was hit
he had the Queen's come off
a5 and it was anything missed here rook
there
the Knights challenged chop chop and now
I'm just the active side here I don't
think it slipped I really wanted to keep
both rooks on around this point it's
just climbing and it's to be expected
you know just the it's a situation of
active rooks versus passive rooks when
you do a piece by piece comparison just
uh better pieces in the end f4 it's a
really big fan of f4 Lex ro k-6 here
with then Bishop to e7 huh and this move
is no good because of this check and
after hook to d8 oh you go straight in
for a pin huh
okay so yeah the rip couldn't leave the
back rank in other words had I played
rook a six and rook here then I get to
make use of the back ring
you have to interpose and then I have an
eventual Bishop g5 chop chop
pin and then eventually win of the
bishop okay so I had rook 86 that would
have been better than if for anything
else MIT's missed here still pawn
advantage it wants to go for f5 I mean I
did have this in mind but I wasn't quite
sure of it
factoring in the time as well one rook
comes off so yeah it's still tough and a
plus for now these pawns are just
marching I mean had something better
around here f5 immediately oh I have
pressure on the bishop there was no king
takes pawn hmm yeah I know it's off the
charts mate you 33 there's computer
chess for you it did pop up for a moment
there mate in 33 yeah I almost saw that
all right yeah I don't think anything
was missed from here but yeah
interesting game it's interesting how
just a single weakness in one's position
right I mean this is all well known this
is this is theory and everything but you
know when when II five is played
immediately one can already think about
doing this Knight transfer in focusing
on doing what establishing a knight in a
in in blacks position at d5 square
should capture one's attention c5 e 5
played D fives the weakness he could die
you have time to go for these types of
this type of maneuver and make use of
that square but anyhow as usual feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comment section below to this video and
as usual I hope you got something out of
it that's all for now
take care